[Music]
in on the same page news submitted by
one minute delivery here's why every
couple needs a relationship contract
what here's why something's up there
something that's how they do all the
titles these days oh yeah is it from
BuzzFeed no this from time I think
contracts would be helpful he's not
girls they always forget every other say
I just call the prenup yeah I know but
like it's just everything in general
like you know the girl like why are you
stuttering are you scared boy watch out
watch out watch I'll say for you like
you talking about how they're always
hypocritical hypocritical changes like
oh sometimes I want this and so what
that with your ear what's going on
watch how Bart watch out watch out we
know that it's good we're good
yeah but uh I finalized hold them
accountable at on time I would be sick
if only oh there's no court of law I can
hold a woman accountable yeah hmm I feel
like she's a substitute teacher who's
just waiting for us all to be quiet so
she can continue oh absolutely
unlock the vibe I have you unlocked it
you ready
so anyway she's having a bad day yeah
well did you wake up on the wrong side
of it let's talk about that she's really
hot look at her she's about to start to
sweating because you miss making her
piss mmm not hyperhidrosis to know I
have a headache
named Bart what even Casey and Jo oh
damn
would you like an alka-seltzer heartburn
relief it doesn't help that he didn't
listen to your diagnosis and he offered
you a solution for something else oh
that's all right so let me tell you
about this relationship contract the
team's a subject so here this article
they're saying that it's pretty so most
successful couples the most successful
couples figure out how they can be
fulfilled in their relationship early on
and that's how they become successful
hmm like how do they fill each other's
cups
fulfilled yeah no I can't ever see you
did you picture two couples with two
cups and they're just filling in each no
I just put I just pictured cute as cups
and they're like oh like two cups that
have faces and they're dancing I picture
you crunching on seaweed really loudly
and then you're like oh like isn't it
nice that they fill their cups yes I'm
uh yeah yeah so there are three three
areas that couple contracting should
cover so it is values boundaries and
fears great I'm gonna need to know this
they wrote more values I will read what
they said what makes you happy and proud
what gives you satisfaction what makes
for a good life these are all questions
that can help you figure out what
matters most to you values are the
yardsticks we use to measure our lives
when our choices and actions align with
our values we feel content when they
don't we feel stressed and unhappy what
matters most to you could range from
specific career goals to having enough
time to pursue to pursue an important
hobby to building financial security to
having an adventurous family life
whatever those values are when couples
are clear about what matters most they
can more easily decide what to pursue
and when they have to go when have to
let go of something it feels like a
willing sacrifice rather than a
regretful trade-off for example if you
and your partner both value family time
more than anything else neither of you
should take a job that requires 70 hour
work weeks even if it is an amazing
career opportunity working less
demanding jobs will allow you to serve
your values I see one huge problem oh
it's one whose problem I'm a chick ask
me what my values are now I want to test
me okay my bad why cuz you're my husband
my wife she wanted to play the role
about you too honey honey I don't know
where'd your values what I don't know I
don't know what do you do this
separately on like seven pacer oh my
word I've had a therapist tell me to do
the same thing with with Robert yeah
that's good but you ain't shut him up
girl
is this how you figure out how to eat
with your wife like I got okay what do
you want you don't even talk to me write
down the four places you want to eat a
ton all right listen what we want to eat
is the food that just shows up in front
of us so take that is not cheesy it is
you said earlier that you want decisions
made because you otherwise you'll do
nothing and you want you want someone to
say like I want this this this that's
not that's not this I always know what I
want to eat I'm never indecisive about
that how much these two are
can you guys help me since I'm the
single one here but not when it comes to
what I want to eat like I know what I'm
having for dinner and I know what I'm
having for dinner tomorrow and the day
after that if someone asks where your
valleys are like I don't know what are
your values cuz I maybe I'll base mine
of yours
you're just cheating them you should be
doing this oh yeah you got to do this
separately and then compare and contrast
well you guys are all [ __ ] already cuz
you're in a marriage our relationship I
still have hope I guess I could restart
it anymore
yes so you heard a big chunk of dialogue
from tip what did you get out of it okay
so know what your values are yeah and I
wrote tits and butts time-space and legs
sometimes smart girls trade-off I
haven't got to that part yet yeah
sometimes smart girls sometimes
sometimes something here when they're
younger two valleys are tits and ass
that's the biggest thing yeah
prioritizing cuz I you know like I don't
want to be too picky I'm not like the
kind of person that's unrealistic right
so then like I have to go what is the
most important tits and butts yeah and
then facing sometimes facing leg I'm not
do I don't want to be unrealistic
because guys out there they're to like I
want a perfect girl that has this and
this but they don't even deserve it what
marriage material all this [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] but I have to be you know like I
want to be like those I want to be more
like down-to-earth yeah so yeah really
more like with the people you know oh
wait what [ __ ] it where what pedestal
are you on right now that you have to go
down with the people use a freedom
fighter WWE match you forget how famous
I am sometimes because we're around each
other but I am kind of somebody to
somebody okay and you go for those
people the people that are that idolize
you
oh of course so Joe what's the perfect
fan the perfect fan base
okay the perfect fan I'll even go lower
than this please they just have to want
me that's it yep yeah that was cute
actually except to be alive but then I
say this and then um I
the main DMS that I get are closeted
meet up middle eastearn men who want to
be my boyfriend like I promise you I
will treat you better than just ever has
yeah I didn't go on their page you go
around
you go in their page it's just it's just
like a it's like a dude that's like in
traditional like Middle Eastern clothes
and stuff and I'm just like wow you were
cooking it good for you he would he's
like I wear nothing but an apron
I would you say to that do I know you're
straight but like you free when I say I
could I could treat you better or
whatever I could be a really good
boyfriend and I'm like damn dude if only
the one I wanted would treat me the way
that they want me you know like you
should try it you never know if it's for
you until you try it you know everyone's
all like if you don't call your girl
sexy some Indian man in the DM will you
know you ever heard of that meat I mean
no well for me in this case a gay
middle-eastern man will write so you
better watch out ladies yeah you believe
me bread or else there'll be a gay
Middle Eastern man that's closeted and
he's gonna try to turn me gay Robert he
did yeah family he one of his biggest
values is his career so I have learned
to kind of tweak mine and my priorities
- so that we can grow together as a
couple without getting into arguments
further in the future we're pulling in
our days oh but you guys match cuz you
love to eat and he loves to cook that's
awesome if he is I mean if he's working
19 our days at least I know where he
[ __ ] is yeah wouldn't you rather have
a hard worker than a man that's a hard
cheater exactly yeah
there is no time to cheat when you're
working that well true so the next one
boundaries it says what are your lines
what are the lines who are unwilling to
cross
are there certain geographical locations
you could not stomach moving to a
long-distance relationship yeah or even
like just moving to like in the future
I don't know like that's how their
payment might move into Fontana or
something like that yeah I don't know
the place no one wants to live but all
to be there or others you don't want to
leave how many how many hours would your
partner have to work each week for your
life
together to become unmanageable how much
work travel can each of you take on
before your relationship starts to
crumble negotiating him and committing
two lines help couples because it
narrows their choices
this may sound counterintuitive but
scores of studies have proven that
having fewer options makes it easier to
choose and makes us happier with our
choices imagine you get offered a great
promotion in a questionable location if
you and your partner have already ruled
out that location outside of your
boundaries then making the decision to
pass on the job will be easier than if
you had to open the conversation about
movie while the offer on the table
complicated your feelings I don't like
how unromantic this is yeah it's so
unromantic yeah I just want to be
everywhere with this person I love them
sweet exercise about getting to know
each other and like really put rules and
regulations around it [ __ ] that [ __ ]
Joe's tits and ass contract was more
romantic no I kind of like it though cuz
it may it forces each partner to really
think about what their boundaries are
what their values are like it forces
them to really think about it instead of
going like with the flow and just being
all romantic and stuff and then finally
realizing that you have something that
just doesn't sit right with you and
you're like wait what the [ __ ] is it
yeah I think it's a couple specific two
or like if you have a couple that's
always talking about romance and all
this affair
retail [ __ ] but they've never
discussed not but they never discussed
like upper and lower thresholds like
like the real parts of the relationship
right I think they need this but if you
have an overly logical couple that
always discuss this they probably don't
need exactly they just need to have fun
that's true because if if I was with the
next girlfriend she's like I really like
to peg and I was like him in the bus and
then and I don't want to be the guy
that's like oh I don't like that and
then she gets all heartbroken cuz she's
like oh but I like that I rather be the
like guy that's like hey just to let you
know I don't like to peg
okay cool like I like it but you know
what thank you for telling me because it
has to change for you you don't change
hmm no no I'm letting her know before
like I let her down
oh I see that's that's I'm a preemptive
strike kind of person she's like I just
said hi it's nice to meet you but I like
to lay down them the whole information
before we get to like right there the
last one here it says you may worry
about your partner's family will in
Roche in your relationship that over
that over time you too will grow a part
that your partner will have an affair
that you will have to sacrifice your
career for your partners that you may
not be able to have children
let's consume emmalin endless it does
when couples gave themselves permission
to think and talk about their fears yeah
build greater mutual sensitivity and
support and can take pre-emptive action
to stop those fears being realized
that's tight communicate with each other
man yeah that's what it comes down to
secret thank you for me I have the most
successful relationship in this room
secrets don't tell her [ __ ]
[Music]